tonight marks a deadline that puts
millions of americans in a financial
crisis with federal unemployment
benefits set to run out
right now the covid relief bill is in
florida where president trump spent
christmas
it's unclear if he will sign it earlier
this week he said he may not
sign it unless lawmakers increase
stimulus payments
from 600 to 2 thousand dollars
believe it or not democrats agree
with the president at least to the
extent that we need to sign this bill
now
congress will return monday for a rare
late december session after republicans
blocked democrats effort
to push through a payment increase
meantime unemployment benefits that are
part of the cares act could end for
nevadans in just a couple of hours
that's if the president does not sign
that relief packet
package that was passed by congress 8
news now reporter madison kimbrough
joins us live in the newsroom tonight
with the latest on the loss of
unemployment benefits or possible loss
rather madison
yeah nevada department of employment
training and rehabilitation also known
as dieter
is ready to administer the benefits of
the coveted relief bill
but if not signed by president trump
today hundreds of thousands of nevadans
and other people around the country will
lose employment benefits unemployment
benefits
benefits like the pandemic emergency
unemployment compensation program
a temporary federal program available
for individuals
who regular unemployment benefits have
either expired or will
soon expire pandemic unemployment
assistance is another program
providing temporary federal aid as part
of the cares act
overall nearly 200 000 nevadans stand to
lose the benefits that they are
currently getting
hr 133 does get signed there are
several unknowns and limitations for us
the department of labor has advised the
state that it will
issue guidance in terms of how to
implement
the program and the requirements under
the new bill
they estimate it will take them about
two weeks to provide that guidance
to the state now these aren't the only
programs being held up emergency food
assistance emergency rental assistance
another round of small business grants
and loans and emergency efforts to stop
people
from becoming homeless are still at a
standstill
president trump has until midnight
tonight to sign the bill reporting live
in the newsroom madison kimbrough 8 news
now